[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Invented
in Holland in 1898,
the deli slicer
launched a revolution
behind the meat counter.
No longer was it
necessary to carve meats
and cheeses entirely by hand.
With a turn of a crank,
the deli slicer produced
precise cuts in a jiffy.
The modern deli slicer is
powered by electricity,
with a manual override for
the carriage that delivers
food to a spinning blade.
Production begins with
a cast aluminum base.
A worker installs
a cam mechanism
that is part of a
system for adjusting
the thickness of the slice.
He threads wiring, connected
to an on/off indicator light
through holes in the base.
Then he screws an index
knob onto the shaft,
protruding from the cam
mechanism installed earlier.
An important warning
label comes next.
Then, he seals the gap around
the blade shaft with silicone
and removes the excess
with soapy water.
Next up is the wiring
for the slicer motor.
She clamps the wires
together and bolts the clamps
to the inside of
the aluminum base.
She inserts the on/off
switch and the plastic trim.
Then attaches a
device that will slide
to adjust the gap between the
gauge plate and the blade.
Thereby, controlling the
thickness of the cut.
The deli slicer is
ready for the slide rod
and carriage sub assembly
that will deliver
food to the spinning blade.
The carriage will
move across a track
that she now attaches
to the lip of the base.
She tests the carriage assembly
to confirm that it's on track.
The next worker
secures the blade motor
to the wiring with bolts.
He connects the motor to the
blade shaft with a drive belt.
Operating the motor allows
him to observe the drive
belt and pulleys in
action, confirming
that they operate smoothly.
Once the gauge
plate is installed,
they move on to
making the blade.
Computer guided cutters
sloped to steel surface
and carve a precise
bevel onto the rim.
It goes from a rough
blank to a precisely
shaped blade in just minutes.
The next worker etches the
company logo and production
date into the blade metal.
Another lathe
pre-sharpens the blade
to the point where it could
cut through something as fine
as several thousands of an inch.
A worker slides the blade
onto the drive shaft
and secures it in
place with a nut.
He now checks the alignment
of the gauge plate in relation
to the blade.
He turns the thickness
mechanism to close the gap
and checks it again.
With a dial indicator, he
measures the position of
the blade even more precisely.
This tool confirms that the
blade is in the exact position
for cutting and
that it won't lose
that position once activated.
This deli slicer comes
with its own sharpening
system, a grinding wheel,
and protective casing.
He mounts the grinder
and activates it to hone
the edge to razor sharpness.
When the blade cuts through
tissue paper cleanly,
it's ready for real
slicing action.
A worker screws the arm for the
sliding tray to the carriage.
He uses a spacer
disk to establish
the correct distance between
the food tray and the blade.
He sets the food tray on
the arm and checks the gap
between it and the blade.
Once the two are correctly
aligned, he removes the spacer
and latches the safety
guard to the blade.
And now for a test, verifying
that the tray doesn't drag or
scrape against the blade guard.
Below, they've installed rods to
move the carriage on the track.
The system can be
manually operated
or driven by a second motor.
Finally, a worker cleans
the slicing machine
until it gleams.
At 135 pounds, this deli
slicer is no lightweight.
So they use a crane to lower
it into the packing box.
Hefty and heavy duty,
this deli slicer
should have what it takes to
cut it at the meat market.